Okay.
This is really important.
You can help us impact the youtube algorithm
that is screwing us over.
Okay, so in this segment I'm going to give
you specific steps that you can take to help
the David Pakman show be prioritized and do
better in YouTube's algorithm.
Now as a reminder, this relates to the fact
that we're experiencing this huge deep prioritization
on Youtube, thanks to a new algorithm, which
is basically saying we're going to give use
to corporate youtube channels instead of independent
channels like the David Pakman show.
And over the last few months we've seen independent
media channels go from sharing about half
of youtube news and politics recommendations
to sharing only about 25% of them.
So basically a dozen corporate youtube channels
and get 75% of the recommendations.
Meanwhile, hundreds or thousands of independent
news channels like mine are sharing just 25%
of the recommendations.
It's horrible.
And what it does for us as a channel is caused
a 3 million view shortfall per month from
what's called youtubes recommended feed.
3 million views per month for us is a lot
of revenue.
Okay, so this is really hurting us.
Hundreds of our subscribers have been Ila
emailing me saying, David, I used to see your
videos recommended.
Now every time I watch one of your videos,
Youtube says, hey, what about watching Fox
News?
Next, what about watching one of the big corporate
late night shows all corporate content?
So there are a few ways that you can help
us reprogram the youtube algorithm.
We have almost 700,000 subscribers on youtube.
We are in the top 1% on youtube, but not in
the top 0.1% which is where the big corporate
channels are.
If enough of our audience follows the steps
I'm about to give you, it would hugely help
to train youtube algorithm in our favor.
So I'll start with the obvious stuff and then
get to the really good stuff.
First of all, don't just watch our videos.
Make sure you are subscribed.
Having subscribers who watch our videos signals
high engagement to Youtube Algorithm and it
helps for us to be prioritized.
So make sure that you are subscribed to the
channel.
Hit the bell icon.
Tell Youtube you want to be notified about
our new videos.
Number two, I know lots of you do this, please.
Like every video that you watch, honestly
even dislike it because either likes or dislikes
our engagement.
Very often, only two to 5% of the audience
for any video will click like or dislike.
If we have a higher like ratio, it will help
us hugely in the algorithm.
So please, like all of our videos that we
upload daily, and if you want, also leave
a comment which signals high engagement to
youtube.
So this is all the simple stuff everybody
will tell you.
But here's where it gets more interesting.
When you're watching a video of ours and you
see all of those corporate media recommendations
down the Sidebar, put your mouse over one
of them and you will see three dots come up.
And then you can click those three dots and
click not interested, and then click on, tell
us why and tell youtube you are not interested
in that channel.
So when it's CNN or MSNBC or Fox News or whatever,
this will number one, retrain your algorithmic
recommendations so that you are more likely
to get independent content recommendations
instead of corporate content.
But it also, from what I'm told will influence
youtube algorithm.
If hundreds of thousands of people are doing
the same thing and liking independent content
and telling youtube you're not interested
in the corporate content.
So any opportunity you get to click on another
video, keep clicking on independent media
including our own videos and keep telling
you tube.
You don't want to see the stuff from the corporate
channels.
This will help.
Okay, let's all do this for the next week.
I will follow the numbers and next week I
will come to you with data as I always do
and we'll see if there's any meaningful change
in the numbers on our channel.
And then of course the best thing we can do
is why are we even dealing with this connection
between our revenue and advertisers?
We can sever that connection altogether.
If we just fun shows we like directly via
membership, then we don't even have to worry
about this stuff.
I don't have to suggest to you how to retrain
Youtube Algorithm and the way you can do that
is go to www.joinpacman.com just get a membership.
It's not a lot of money.
Uh, if even a few bucks a month is a bit much
for you right now, you can go to Patrion at
patrion.com/david Pakman show and just throw
a dollar a month at us.
Okay, $1 a month.
This is incredible actually.
Even if you watched every single one of our
videos every month, we wouldn't make a dollar
off of you in terms of ad revenue on Youtube.
You can more than make up for the lost ad
revenue from your individual viewership just
by throwing at us $1 per month on Patrion.
So consider those things.
I will come back to you next week with more
information about how things are working with
these treatments.
A quick break right back